[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHROW: Good afternoon.
My name is Heathrow, and I'm
a research operations manager
on the Insights Lab,
part of Brand Studio,
and we're here today for
a talk by Gloria Mark.
Gloria Mark is a professor in
the Department of Informatics
at the University of
California in Irvine,
and her research focuses on
how the use of technology
affects our lives in
real-world contexts.
She received her
PhD in psychology
from Columbia University,
and before working at UCI
she worked at the German
National Research Center
for Information
Technology and has
served as a visiting
researcher at Microsoft
Research since 2012 as well
as IBM and the MIT Media Lab.
Today she's going to talk
about her work using sensors,
experience sampling, computer
logging, and repeated surveys
to study the
workplace experience,
specifically how attention,
focus, stress, and affect are
impacted by digital media use
as well as how our attention
focus varies over the workday.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Gloria Mark.
GLORIA MARK: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So it's a real pleasure to be
here, so far away from Irvine.
So I am really interested in
understanding how digital media
affects our lives.
And-- how does this clicker--
oops.
OK.
So my starting point
is that most people
are by nature monochronic.
And what that means
is most people,
like myself, prefer
to start on a task
and finish it
through to completion
before switching
to something else.
But we live in a digital
age and we are required
to work in a polychronic way.
So most people have
multiple devices.
You work on multiple
applications.
You have multiple apps open
on your laptop, desktop.
Some people have iPads.
And were always switching
our attention between devices
and applications,
and it forces us
to work in a polychronic
way, and that's
against what our nature is.
So in particular I'm very
interested in the idea
of multitasking.
And people sometimes think
of multitasking as working
on two things at the same time.
And that's impossible
for human beings
to literally work on two
things at the same time.
You can walk and
chew gum, but this is
an unconscious kind of process.
But what it really refers
to is switching very rapidly
between different tasks,
between different contexts.
You can think of it like
time-sharing among computers.
Right?
So when we talk about
multitasking, that's really
what we're referring
to, this rapid
context-shifting back and forth.
Now, a lot of people have
tried to measure multitasking.
And the most typical
way that it's measured
is you ask people, how
much do you multitask?
Well, this is not very
fruitful because research
has shown that people
can be off by about 30%
in their estimates
of how much time they
spend on computing or just
estimating time in general.
People are notoriously
bad at estimating time.
You can bring people
in a laboratory
and you can give them some
kind of artificial task
and watch how fast or
how well they switch,
but that's artificial
and it doesn't
begin to model all
the kinds of things
we experience in real-world
work, like career trajectories
and conflicts and social
pressures and deadlines
and how tired we feel and so on.
So my perspective
is that if we really
want to study people
and understand them,
we have to go where people are.
So we have to create
living laboratories.
And that's what I do.
And if you do this
kind of approach
we can ask questions like, how
fragmented is our attention
with digital media?
How can we explain distraction
How does digital
media use affect mood?
Because it does.
So let me start off by
talking about the introduction
of digital media
in the workplace.
So I'm very often
asked, well gee,
didn't people always multitask?
You know, what is
new about this?
So let's take a look.
So unfortunately nobody
has done any study
at the level of
detail that we have
where we use sensors and track
behavior to the second, which
I'll talk about shortly.
But what people have done
is they-- historically
they followed people
around in the workplace
and they've timed them to see
what their distribution of time
is with different activities.
And if you look here at these--
all the studies that are
represented in the two
right columns
represent studies that
were done when personal
computing and email became
widespread in use
in the workplace.
And the studies to the left--
they were not really
in widespread use.
The study, Stevens et al,
1992, was sort of mixed.
And I want you to
look in particular
at how desk work
has changed and how
scheduled meetings--
"scheduled meetings"
refers to formally-scheduled
face-to-face meetings.
And I want you to look at
these two columns on the right
and contrast that with the
work done by the other studies.
And the Horne and Lupton study
in 1965 with scheduled meetings
is a bit of an anomaly.
And tell me if you
notice any trends here.
Do you notice anything?
What do you notice?
What's changed?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GLORIA MARK: Huh?
GLORIA MARK: OK.
The amount of time spent
at the desk is increasing.
And what about-- and
meetings are decreasing.
So if we put these
two trends together
we see that the
proportion of time
spent at desk work
nearly doubled
with the introduction
of IT in the workplace.
And people spend
a less proportion
of their time in scheduled,
face-to-face meetings.
And this suggests that
work that was formerly
done in face-to-face
meetings is now
being done, to a larger extent,
at the desktop through email,
through desktop conferencing,
through other kinds of means.
So I'm very fortunate to
be interested in this topic
at the cusp of a revolution
in the development of sensor
technology, wearable
technologies and other kinds
of sensor technologies.
And so my students and I used to
track people in the workplace.
We used to shadow people.
And we had these timers, and
every time people would take
a different action--
like pick up the phone,
we would do start time, they'd
put the phone down, stop time--
and recorded every single
action that people did.
And it was very,
very labor-intensive.
But the advantage is that we
could understand the context.
Right?
So as a byproduct of
measuring these activities
we got a sense of what
people's work life was like.
But when you use sensors
you miss that context.
Right?
The sensors are just
recording bits of information.
And so the grand challenge,
as I see it, is to what extent
can we automatically
capture behavior
with sensors to gain the
same level of Insights,
the same level of deep knowledge
we can about human behavior
that we could with human
ethnographic observation?
Ethnographic observation is when
people actually follow people
around and observe.
And I have several projects
that I've been working on.
Today I will only talk
about the Health Sense
Project, which is dealing
with information workers.
I have another large study,
the Millennial Project,
which tracked college students
and their use of digital media.
So let me go through
the measures that I use,
because this is going to
help you understand the data.
So we measure stress
using heart rate monitors.
We measure electro
dermal activity
using these devices that are
called Affectiva Q sensors.
Actually, these days we're
using other wearable devices.
We measure people's mood
and focus through something
called "experience sampling."
These are probes
that people get where
they record their subjective
opinion about something.
And I'm going to talk
about that later.
That's in the
upper-right, as an example
of what a probe looks like.
We measure face-to-face
interaction with sense cams,
as this lower-right picture.
It's a small little camera,
very lightweight, people wear.
It takes continual photos
about every 20 or 30 seconds.
And then we can apply
face detection software
to see if there was a face
present or not in the image.
And it's very accurate.
We log people's computer
and phone activity
we measure people's
activity using
actigraphs, which
everyone knows of Fitbit
as a common actigraph.
We measure sleep, sleep rhythms.
And we give a whole lot of
demographic and personality
kinds of measures.
So let me start by giving
you an example of what
your digital media use
can reveal about you.
Now, some people have
done this kind of work
where they mined the content.
So they analyze the content.
For example, in
social media they
do sentiment analysis to
see what kind of words
people are using.
But if we just look
at temporal features--
no content, but
temporal features
like the average
amount of time you
spend on digital
media, the dispersion,
are you using it all at one time
or using it throughout the day?
When is the device on and off?
How much social
media are you using?
Again, not content.
What's your rhythm of usage?
Do you have a regular
pattern, or is it irregular?
What time of day is
that mostly used?
And we find that we can
predict personality.
These are the big five
personality traits,
if you're familiar with them.
This is a commonly-used
measure of personality.
We can predict these traits
from temporal features
alone with fairly high accuracy.
So let's start with a
question very much related
to multitasking, which
is how fragmented
are people's attention
in the workplace?
And by "fragmented," how much do
they actually switch contexts?
OK.
So here is a measure from
logging people's computer
activity.
This is the average
duration of time
that people spend on
any computer screen
before switching.
And if you look at
all computer usage,
the median length of
time is 40 seconds.
That means that every
40 seconds people
are switching on average--
well, it's actually the median--
to another screen.
That's a very short
amount of time.
And if we look at averages
of how often people switch
within apps-- that
means you open up Word,
and then you're opening up
other documents within word
or you're surfing the internet--
people switch about 112 times
a day.
And switching between apps,
which is even more of a context
shift--
going from the internet to
a Word document to email--
that's about 261 times a day.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GLORIA MARK: No.
This-- sorry.
That is seconds,
but the switches
within apps and
between apps actually
refer to number of instances.
Sorry about that.
That should be
labeled differently.
So people's workday
typically is characterized
by very short durations of
attention on any computer
screen and lots of switching.
There is an assumption made,
that when a computer screen is
in the forefront and active, we
make an assumption that that's
a proxy for attention.
And it's not always the case.
Now, we do have decision rules.
So if a screen comes up really
quick and then goes off,
we make this assumption
that people's
attention-- it's not long enough
for people to really focus.
Right?
To have any kind of
meaningful focus.
So we have decision
rules where we filter out
screens that are just up for
very brief moments of time.
So, for example, sometimes
people might switch--
click on a web page and
then click immediately
to something else,
so we disregard
that because we can't expect
that people are actually
going to focus and spend
cognitive resources when
that shift is so fast.
The median focus duration on
any computer screen, we find,
is 40 seconds.
Now, we wondered that maybe--
you know, not
everybody is alike.
Maybe there are individual
differences that
can explain focus duration.
And so we hypothesize
that the following things
would be related to
the amount of time
that people would spend
focused on any computer screen.
Neuroticism is a
personality trait.
It's characterized by people
who just can't suppress thoughts
that come into your head.
And people who are
highly-neurotic
generally have short
attention spans.
We hypothesize that
people who are impulsive
would have a shorter attention
span on the computer.
There are two dimensions of
impulsivity that we checked.
One is a sense of urgency.
Right?
You can't hold yourself back.
You just have to act.
Another dimension,
lack of perseverance.
Right?
That people just
don't have what it
takes to persevere on a task.
People who are
susceptible to stress.
And we hypothesize that
people who did not sleep,
did not have long sleep
durations the night
before would have shorter
attention durations.
And we also hypothesized
that the longer the attention
duration on any
computer screen would
be associated with a higher
assessed productivity
at the end of the day.
And the neuroticism and
impulsive urgency hypotheses
were supported.
There was a strong trend for
the sleep and stress hypotheses
to be supported,
and productivity.
This hypothesis was supported.
So we also did what's called
a "factor analysis," where
we put all these
variables into a program
to see if there's a latent
structure in the variables.
And indeed, we found
a latent variable
that we label "lack of control,"
which is comprised of people
that are high in neuroticism,
who are high in this impulsive
urgency kind of variable, and
people who are susceptible
to stress.
And this is predictive.
The more lack of control
people have, the shorter
is their focus duration.
And I'm going to come back to
this idea of lack of control
later on.
Now you might be
asking, well, so what?
So what if I switch from
Excel to Word to email?
But what if I'm working
on the same project?
Right?
Maybe it doesn't
make a difference.
Right?
Because right now
I'm just talking--
I'm agnostic to
task and I'm just
talking about these switches
between computer screens.
So let's go a little
bit deeper and let's
look at the task level.
This is work that was done by a
former student of mine, Victor
Gonzalez, with great effort,
who categorized these smaller
actions, clustering them
into different tasks.
And it took him a
great deal of time.
And here's what he found.
That, first of all,
people work on an average
of about 12 different projects.
We call these "working
spheres," spheres of work.
And people spend about
10 and a half minutes
in any of these working
spheres before switching
to something else.
So 10 and a half minutes is not
a really long period of time.
And I know-- you know, I'm an
academic and I write papers,
and 10 and a half minutes
is not a very long time
for me to get sufficiently
deep into beginning a task,
and then I'm switching.
So let's look at rhythms
of attention over the day.
So I want to give you a little
bit of psychology theory.
So there's a number
of researchers
who've talked about this
idea of attention focus.
And it goes by different names.
It goes by the term
"cognitive absorption."
Others have called it
"cognitive engagement."
How many of you have
heard of mindfulness?
OK.
You're living in LA.
You know about mindfulness.
How many of you
have heard of flow?
OK.
Flow is the idea that
you're so deeply immersed
with your attention that
you become completely
unaware of the passage of time.
So all of these
ideas are related.
And then in contrast
people speak about boredom.
And the research shows that all
of these different constructs
related to attention
are associated
with positive affect.
People are happy when they're
deeply immersed and engaged.
And when they're bored
generally people are not happy.
And that's what the
research studies show.
So here's how you might
conceptualize attention,
being highly engaged or not
engaged in some activity.
Right?
That's a simple continuum.
And so we thought about
this and we hypothesized
that there would be an
orthogonal dimension
that we call "challenge."
And we came up with this idea
because the concept of flow
involves challenge.
When people are in
a state of flow,
they're also challenged
to some degree.
And so we came up with
this conceptual framework
and we put labels on these.
And let me explain them.
So people who are highly-engaged
and highly-challenged we
use a label of focus.
This is when people are
in a state of focus.
And if people are really
engaged in something
but they're not
at all challenged
we call this rote,
as in rote work.
An example is playing solitaire.
Right?
When people play solitaire
you're really engaged,
but you're not challenged.
And the other label,
bored, is when
you're not at all challenged
and you're just not engaged.
We label that "bored."
And the last one is being
challenged in something,
but you're not engaged.
We call that "frustrated."
It's just a label.
An example would be a software
developer who has a bug.
They're just really,
really frustrated.
They're challenged
by it, and they just
can't engage themselves
into trying to work it out.
I mentioned that this is
the probe that we used.
So we gave people these
probes throughout the day.
On the average about 18 times
a day people were asked--
the top part is called
"Russell's circumplex
model of mood."
It's a well-validated measure
of self-reported mood.
And at the bottom we ask
people, how engaged were you
in the thing you
were just doing,
and how challenged were you in
the thing you were just doing?
People were trained
in this, and they
were able to answer these
probes within a few seconds.
These probes came
about 18 times a day.
And the irony is not lost on
me that we're interrupting
people 18 times a day.
But we got really great data.
And people submit this.
We get a time stamp, and we
can align the time stamp.
So we see what people's
subjective moods and engagement
and challenge is in relation
to the computer activities
that they're doing.
And we also look at stress
and we have other measures.
So in contrast to what all
this other research shows,
that people are happiest
when they're engaged,
we actually find that the
mean level of happiness
is highest when people
are doing rote work.
So when people are doing
this kind of mindless work--
you're engaged but
you're just not using
your mental resources-- that's
when people are the happiest.
So if we slice up this idea
of engagement and attention
and we slice it up in
terms of being challenged
and not challenged, we
find there is a difference.
People are least happiest
when they're bored.
And you're saying, why are there
data lines with frustrated?
That's because hardly
anyone in our sample
reported being frustrated.
So we didn't have enough
data to make any conclusions.
This is what the
average attention
looks like over the
course of the day.
The black line is
focused, and there's
a couple of interesting
things about this graph.
So people are at their
peak focus in the morning--
about 11:00 AM,
so late morning--
and also roughly about 3:00 PM.
And what's also interesting,
at least for me,
is that people don't come
into the workplace ramped up
and ready to go, but
it takes some time
to ease into a deeper
attentional state.
Let's talk about distractions.
So first an interesting
idea about interruptions
is, we always think of
interruptions in terms
of external notification.
Right?
You get an email notification
or a social media notification
or a colleague comes
into the office
or you get a phone ringing.
But there's this
other phenomenon
we call "internal
interruptions," or self
interruptions.
The best way I can describe it
is, you're observing someone
and they're typing on a Word doc
and for no apparent reason they
suddenly stop what they're
doing and they turn
and pick up the phone.
Or they stop and they check
email or social media.
That's a self interruption.
I know I do it.
Since I've been
doing this research
I became much more aware
of how much I do it.
Now we took the data
and we divided it up
into hourly segments
and we looked
at the proportion of external
and internal interruptions
in each of those hourly
segments throughout the day
over the course of
days, and we found
something really interesting.
That when external
interruptions waned,
we saw that internal
interruptions kicked in
and started to become high.
It's not that when an
external interruption
stopped that people
suddenly had peace of mind
and were able to work
without interruptions.
They began to
interrupt themselves.
That's what the data showed.
And this suggests
to me that people
are conditioned to be
interrupted to work
in very short attention spans.
And if you're not
being interrupted
by external sources, then people
will interrupt themselves.
And that would be a sign
of being conditioned.
OK.
Now distractions.
A lot of work has been
done in interruptions.
And people have
assumed in this work
that people are really
absorbed in their work,
and then along
comes a distraction
and all of a sudden
people get bored.
Right?
Along comes this social
media distraction
and then it takes you away
from this deep engagement.
Well, what if it's the reverse?
What if people are first
in a state of boredom,
and that makes them
susceptible to a distraction?
And so that's the
question we asked.
So first let me tell
you a little bit
about types of interruptions.
So workplace communications
comprise 40% of interruptions.
There's email.
These are the top offenders.
Email is primarily work-related,
at least in the workplaces
we studied they were.
Face-to-face can be either
work-related or social.
And Facebook, which was
the main social media
platform used in the
particular company we studied.
That's primarily social.
And to give you an idea
of the extent to how often
and how much people spend on
these types of communications,
we see people in our sample
visited Facebook about 21 times
a day, email-checked
about 74 times a day.
The high person in our sample
was about 465 times a day.
But people spend relatively
short durations of time.
They check Facebook, but then
spend about 18 seconds on it.
And email-- you know,
they check it often,
but spend just about 32 seconds.
So they don't-- this
is the typical profile
of the information
worker who we studied.
And here's what we find
when we looked at the data.
We found, based on this
experience-sampling
from the probes, that when
people were in a state of focus
they spent significantly
longer on email
compared to the other states and
the other communication types.
When people were either bored or
in a state of doing rote work,
they spent significantly longer
doing face-to-face interaction
after.
And when people were
in a state of rote work
it was followed
significantly by a longer
duration of Facebook use.
And the way to
interpret this data
is that people first adopt
particular attentional states,
particular states
of mind, which make
them susceptible to particular
kinds of interaction.
Let's talk about email.
So it took me six years
to find a field site that
was willing to let
itself be cut off,
to have its employees be cut
off by email for a work week.
And the reason we wanted
to study this was to see--
can we create an
environment where
people would have
less interruptions,
could they focus longer?
Right?
And so here's what we found.
We had people in this workplace.
We measured them in
their baseline condition,
and then we cut off their
email for a work week,
and we had them wear
heart rate monitors which
provides a measure of
heart rate variability.
It's the variability
of the distance
between consecutive heartbeats.
And we find that
without email people
spend significantly
longer duration of focus
on any computer screen.
And then the flip side-- if
you want to look at the data
from the flip side, you can see
that they switched about half
as often.
Now, heart rate
variability revealed
that people were
significantly less stressed.
You're looking at
that number and you're
saying, wait a minute.
It's higher.
How can that be?
That's because the higher
the variability of people's
heart rate intervals, the
intervals between the beats,
the more relaxed people are.
And that's because the
least little bit of stimulus
will cause you to jump.
Right?
And it creates
higher variability.
If you're really stressed
you're in this fight or flight
kind of syndrome.
You know, the bear is chasing.
You're ready to run.
And your heart beats
are more irregular.
So we find longer focus
and we find people are less
stressed without email.
Let's talk about workplace
mood and social interactions.
So there's two ways to
measure workplace mood.
So first of all we
wanted to see if people's
face-to-face interaction
would produce
a different kind of
mood in the workplace
than online social interactions.
And again, as I
mentioned, Facebook
was the most common platform
used in this company.
There's two ways
of looking at this.
At the time they occur,
what makes people happier?
And so let me ask you, how
many of you think of the time
they occur face-to-face
interactions make
people happier than Facebook?
How many of you think--
OK.
How many of you think that
Facebook-- doing a Facebook
interaction makes
people happier?
OK.
The answer is face-to-face.
We can also look at this
at the end of the day.
Because this is
really important,
because the mood people
have at the end of the day
carries over into
their personal lives.
So this is really
important to look at.
How many of you think the
more time spent on Facebook
is associated with a happier
mood at the end of the day?
How many of you
think the more time--
wait.
Sorry.
Did I say face-to-face?
I meant to say, how many
think face-to-face--
the more time spent in
face-to-face interaction
at the workplace is
associated with a happier mood
at the end of the day?
OK.
And how many of you think the
more time spent on Facebook
is associated with a happier
mood at the end of the day?
We have one person.
And one person, you are correct.
It is Facebook.
The more time people
spend on Facebook.
Now, why would that be the case?
Right?
It's counterintuitive.
Well, we dug into
the data and we
found that when people
spent more time on Facebook
they were also more engaged
in their work for that day.
And now it makes sense.
Because if you're
really working,
you're really focused
and engaged in your work,
the last thing you want to have
is a face-to-face interaction.
Because when you have a
face-to-face interaction,
you're a prisoner
of that interaction.
Right?
You have the greeting ritual and
the interaction and the parting
ritual, and you can't just
break away very quickly.
But with Facebook you can do
what we call grazing behavior.
You can move in and out pretty
quickly under your control.
And so that's why we think
when people were engaged
in their work
Facebook offers them
a way to do grazing
behavior, to take breaks
under their control.
So what about if we
block distractions?
What happens?
Is it a good strategy
to block distractions?
Everybody complains
about distractions
from digital media.
And there's just a
plethora of commercial apps
that are developed to enable
people to block distractions.
Two basic approaches.
One is you just
simply cut off sites
that people feel
would be distracting.
And the other approach
is that you show people
the amount of time they spend
on different sites to increase
their awareness, with the
idea that if people become
aware how much time they
spend on social media
they might take
action to change.
So we did a field study,
32 information workers.
We looked around for a
commercial software to use.
We found Freedom
software, which seemed
like a pretty good choice.
We measured people
five days, baseline,
the way they work normally,
and then five days they
worked-- but they were told to
work as they normally would,
but they used this
Freedom blocking software
to block distractions.
We let people choose
what distractions
they wanted to block.
It comes with a default
list of distractions,
and then people
could personalize it
according to what they felt
was most distracting for them.
We used a scale that's called
cognitive absorption, which
has the following dimensions.
These are all related
to the idea of focusing.
And we found that when
distractions were cut off
people's focused
immersion in their task
increased significantly.
Temporal dissociation decreased.
Temporal dissociation is
being unaware of time.
People became more aware of time
when distractions were blocked.
There was no difference in
people's sense of control,
which totally surprised us.
We thought there would be.
And people's
enjoyment decreased.
Well, we took away
people's social media.
And there was no difference in
curiosity, another dimension.
Focus increased.
We interviewed everyone.
Two main reasons.
We removed what's called
"attention residue."
That's the idea of-- let's
say you go on Facebook.
You become involved
in the content,
and that content stays with you.
And when you switch
back to your task
you're still thinking
about Facebook.
We took that residue away.
We stopped chains
of distraction.
People report just
rabbit-holing.
They go on to the
internet and then they
just, before they know it
they're just kind of lost.
But when we looked
at the interviews
we found there are actually two
very distinct groups of people,
those who reported being high
in self-control of their work
and those who
reported being low.
And indeed, when we
did some more analyses
we found people who
had high self-control
were significantly
more conscientious.
It's a personality trait.
And they were significantly
less impulsive.
OK.
Now we went back and
we looked at the data
again in terms of these
two different groups,
and we found something
really interesting.
That the low self-control
group, when their distractions
were blocked, there
really was no difference
in their work load, the
amount of mental expenditure
that they had.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GLORIA MARK: TLX is
the NASA TLX scale.
It's the measure of workload.
So it's a very common,
very well-validated scale
that's used for workload.
However we found
something interesting with
the high self-control group.
People who are very
conscientious people--
that means they're very
diligent in their work,
people who feel that they're
in control of their work--
when distractions were
cut off, guess what?
Their workload
increased significantly.
So we found this
interesting interaction.
Why is that the case?
Well, the reason
is because these
are diligent people, work hard,
and they did not take breaks.
Whereas the people who
had low self-control,
they took physical breaks.
They went to the
coffee room more.
They interacted
with people more.
But people who were very
high in self-control
continued to work straight
through without breaks.
So, of course, their
workload increased.
And their stress
increased significantly.
One person missed her shuttle
at the end of the day.
It never happened before because
she was so immersed in work
and didn't even take any breaks.
So we see there is
individual differences
in the use of this kind of
software to block distractions.
People with low
self-regulation--
we see they're more likely
to take physical breaks.
We see less cognitive switching.
So they did focus
significantly longer.
And so we hypothesized
that the purpose
of this kind of software--
it's to offload this regulation
ability to the software.
People don't have that ability,
it's not innate for them,
so they off-load it
onto the software.
People who already have
high self-regulation--
well when they used this kind of
software to block distractions
they worked longer, fewer
physical breaks, and as
a result higher workload.
And so our hypothesis is that
using this kind of software
actually interferes
with people's ability
to self-regulate.
Right?
They do pretty
well on their own.
And so this whole idea
of this huge business
in distraction blocking
software, that one size fits
all-- it's not true.
So there's a lot
of opportunities
to improve work experience
based on this work.
For example, we can think about
balancing rote and focused work
throughout the day.
Right?
We don't want to
overload people.
We want to think about
balancing people's moods.
We can think about
scheduling work
based on attention
patterns, and we can also
think it's an opportunity
for interventions
that can nudge people to
increase focus, reduce
stress, and improve their mood.
And this idea of
nudging is something
I've been thinking
about quite a bit.
And thinking about
blocking distractions,
but only for those
with low control.
OK.
Now I'm going to put on my
psychologist hat to close here.
OK?
So bear with me.
Throughout the
history of psychology
there has always been this
idea that people take actions
in order to achieve a kind
of balanced emotional and
psychological state.
It's this common thread
through eons of research.
Hippocrates talked about this
idea of harmonious balance
with health.
And Gestalt theorists, if
you're familiar with them,
talked about the
law of pragmats.
Cannon talked about homeostasis.
My favorite psychologist
of all is Kurt Lewin
who talked about this
idea of field theory, who
said that everything we do
in life, every action we take
is designed to reduce tension.
Because tension
is uncomfortable.
And you're probably familiar
with cognitive dissonance
theory, which also is this
idea of how people can reduce
this kind of imbalance
between their attitudes
and their behaviors.
And so I would like to
leave you with this idea
that maybe people adjust
their use of digital media
in order to try to achieve
an internal balance.
So because information
workers spend a good part--
most of their day working
with digital media,
maybe people use
it in such a way
that they're trying to
create this internal balance.
So the way they
take breaks or don't
take breaks, or the
kinds of applications
they choose to work on.
I want to quickly talk
about another project
that I've just been
starting, working on.
This Is the largest
sensing project yet
that we have ever done
and, to my knowledge,
that anyone has ever
done in the workplace.
And the idea here is to predict
the workplace experience.
So people's health
and well-being
using unobtrusive sensors.
That's really key.
We can't introduce
any kind of sensors.
That would disrupt
people's work experience.
Our goal is to track 750
workers over one year.
We have to date about
708 in the study,
and we want it to
be for a whole year
because then we can
track life events.
We can look at what is the
effect of significant life
events like births and deaths
and job changes and marriages
and divorces.
And we can look at seasons
and how that affects.
And how all of this can be fed
into the sensor data to help
understand how it affects
people's work lives.
And we will use a
robust sensing system
comprised of wearable
devices, beacons, phone agent.
And we will use social media,
but not look at content.
We will just look at metadata.
And you can learn more here.
This work could
not have been done
without the collaboration
of a number of really great
colleagues who are listed here.
And I'd like to thank
funders and our participants.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So if anyone has any questions?
HEATHROW: We have
the question box.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: What's the
difference between being bored
and stressed?
GLORIA MARK: Between what?
AUDIENCE: Boredom and stress.
Low stress.
How do you distinguish
low stress from boredom?
GLORIA MARK: Oh.
OK.
So they are actually related.
But you can have low
stress and be happy.
So there is this circumplex
model of mood where
if you have--
you can have low energy
and negative affect.
And that's different from
having negative affect
and high energy.
That quadrant, negative
affect, high energy,
would be defined as stress.
And the quadrant of negative
affect and low energy
would be related to boredom.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So most
of your explanations
are in terms of mood being
affected by what work you do.
To what extent do you
think your data might
be a case of what
work you choose
to do depending on your mood?
GLORIA MARK: Oh, fascinating.
We actually can't
design causality.
Right?
And I did not mean to
imply causality here.
It's all correlation.
Just like with these
huge medical studies--
you know, like smoking
and lung cancer.
We can't imply causality.
So we can't disentangle that.
Right?
And it would be an
interesting study,
but that would have to be
more of an experimental nature
to be able to induce
different kinds of moods
and then to see what kind
of work people choose.
But it's hard when you're
just tracking people
in these kinds of
observational studies
to try to infer causality.
But it's a good question.
AUDIENCE: How does
this thing work?
So this is information
workers so it's presumably
an open office sort of a set up?
GLORIA MARK: Mixed.
It's mixed.
Actually, most of them were
not in open office settings.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Do you think that has
any bearing on, like,
attention and things like that?
GLORIA MARK: Yes.
So it certainly has a
bearing on interruptions.
And so in other work we
found that, in an open office
setting, people were
more likely to be
interrupted for work that
was peripheral to what
they were doing.
Right?
So your colleague says,
help me debug this,
or what's your opinion on this?
And it's not work for
which they are accountable.
It's not tasks that
they're assigned to do.
This happens more in
open office settings.
Is that a good thing
or a bad thing?
Well, you know, if you ask
individuals they might say,
well, it's not a good thing.
If you ask management
they might say, yeah.
That's a good thing.
We're sharing expertise.
So--
AUDIENCE: What about
a sense of agency?
Like you're saying--
so it seems like it's
a competition of wills.
Right?
Who's going to win out?
Is management going to win
out or is the individual?
GLORIA MARK: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: So do you think
an open office deprives
workers of a sense of agency?
In other words, in determining
when they'll be distracted,
and that kind of a thing?
GLORIA MARK: Yeah.
That's really interesting.
I'm not sure I would
use the word "agency."
I would-- I would
guess that people
who have a strong sense of
agency, high self-regulation,
should be able to
somehow create barriers.
But this would be at a cost
of perhaps being asocial
and not being good colleagues.
So there is this social
trade-off as well.
Right?
That it's not just
agency, it's the idea
you want to be a good
organizational citizen.
Right?
And you want to expend
social capital so that you
get social benefits in
return someday, someday when
you have a problem
and you want to be
able to tap into someone
else's expertise.
So I think there is a lot of
interesting things at play.
Agency is perhaps one
thing, but there's all kinds
of social dynamics as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GLORIA MARK: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So as part of
that about causation.
But with the longitudinal
data that you're
planning, you will
know something
about mood before people
start work, and then can
you then look at what
they choose to do?
GLORIA MARK: Yeah.
Absolutely.
So with this we can
look at time series
when we have this kind
of longitudinal data.
I mean, we've looked
at people over weeks.
Right?
And to some extent we can
see this kind of causality
based on time.
But I would be a lot
more confident to look
at it over a much
longer period of time.
I mean, for example, we know
that weather affects mood.
It's causality.
Because it's not the
other way around.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
So we can look at
factors like that.
And, you know, how does the
stock market or, you know,
factors that are really
external to the workplace
and how that's affecting people.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
GLORIA MARK: And it's also
kind of cyclic behavior.
For example, I have
looked at sleep debt.
Sleep debt is the accumulation
of loss of sleep over time.
And you can-- it's kind
of a cyclic pattern
because if you don't
get a lot of sleep
we find that people spend more
time on lightweight activities
like social media,
Facebook, because it's easy.
Right?
And then you sleep less.
Oh, maybe it's because you
didn't get your work done
and you need to
work longer hours.
So there can be these
kinds of cyclical effects.
OK?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]